on va changer de sujet est alors pour le
coup d'endroits dans le monde c'est tout
à fait différent à la fois sur le fond
du sujet puisque nous l'évoquions à
l'instant ce sont les berbères alors sur
notre carte du monde ça nous amène à
partir en avion comme vous voulez de
paris
et puis à descendre vers le haut atlas
marocain cette chaîne de montagnes qui
culminent à ces eaux à 4 à 4000 mètres
qui est pas très loin de marrakech et
dans laquelle nous avons choisi un
village berbère tout à fait typique qui
vit à une altitude relativement élevé à
2 mm est complètement isolée de la
vallée par un col qui est plein de neige
pendant trois ou quatre mois
vous allez voir c'est un style de vie
assez différent du nôtre et claude
lefébure qui est ici donc nous parlera
de la façon de vivre des berbères vous
allez voir ce sont des images qui vont
vous emmener assez loin regardez
hot atlas marocain où aller d aït
bougmez il est 6h30 du matin
tél
et mac os
daboub août à 40 ans prépare le café
elle attend son fils youssef de retour
de la ville
il doit passer la montagne ce matin 7
heures il n'est plus haut dans les
montagnes de wau good that une petite
caravane
cette caravane amène d'azilal la ville
la plus proche de tissus et puis aussi
le cev 7h30 irin le village du gearing
s'éveille
sur le toit de la maison familiale
mohamed 60 ans le père de youssef
[Musique]
8 heures la caravane dépasse le lac gelé
on n'est plus maintenant qu'à 2h du
village
[Musique]
on
non
à 10h les mines et les hommes atteignent
le village la vallée où il n'y a ni
électricité ni eau courante passe les
mois d'hiver en autarcie
chacun a fait provision pour trois mois
de blé de semoule de riz et de thé c'est
difficile de vivre c'est le problème de
l'alimentation
parce que noah en réserve pour les trois
mois d'hiver
en plus des palais à zhouqu
par exemple azilal c'est difficile parce
qu'il ya les cours qui sont encore des
taux d'intérêt ce qui te couper
complètement
[Musique]
chaque famille vit sur elle même et nous
de vaches des poules des lapins les
quelques moutons qui ne sont pas partis
vers des pâturages plus au sud
tout est fait à la maison le pain le
tissage le beurre
[Musique]
un homme ne peut pas vivre sans femme
une maison non plus
l'homme a besoin d'une femme qu'il aime
dans ses travaux et aussi au chant les
femmes font tous les travaux sauf le
labour c'est comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
holger eichele 15 heures youssef rejoint
son père aux gens familiale
[Musique]
celle d'hier
[Applaudissements]
dans ce monde de sable et de pierres
qu'est le haut atlas
la relative prospérité des gens d'ici
les aït bougmez ne s'explique que par un
travail inlassable un travail de la
terre un travail de l'eau
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il heureux
dimanche à l'aube
[Musique]
le premier thé matinal pour youssef et
ses amis avant le départ pour le sun
soupe de la vallée atalante 30
kilomètres plus bas
mohamed le père ouvre sa boutique
j'ai quitté la vallée en 56 secours
allaient à l'armée royale pendant six
ans quand je suis revenue
mon père vivait encore alors j'ai
construit ma propre maison
j'ai acheté cette machine à coudre
c'était la première ici dans le haut de
la vallée
et puis en 85 comme mon père est mort on
a partagé les champs avec mon frère
10 heures
le souk de ta bande
tassé pierre bédard
m
[Musique]
atalante on trouve tout ce qui n'est pas
de première nécessité les fruits des
vêtements des bonbons et même de
l'administration
15h la fin du souk youssef profite du
seul camion de la semaine qui remonte
vers le haut de la vallée
le haut de la vallée où quelques enfants
rêvent de voiture
[Musique]
bien sûr nous soit moi à quoi bon quand
on a tous moynan elle pense qu'une
partie doit pas d'avis
[Musique]